[Música]
a qué generación deseas llegar
cuando tenía 10 años en el verano mi
papá solía llevarla a su trabajo me
encantaba pasar tiempo ahí él se
dedicaba a vender bicicletas y aunque
apenas era una niña me gustaba ayudarlo
armar piezas platicar con sus
colaboradores ir a la tienda por dulces
y subirme a todo lo que estaba en
exhibición
disfrutaba mucho aquellas posadas en las
cuales mis primos mis hermanas y yo
éramos los elegidos para entregar los
premios a todos los bajadores
pero creo que lo que más me gustaba era
ver tan contento a mi papá haciendo lo
que más le apasionaba junto con su
familia el negocio iba muy bien
pero de pronto las cosas empezaron a
cambiar mi papá empezó a llegar a la
casa cada vez más molesto estresado y de
vernos frecuentemente como familia cada
vez nos veíamos menos
tiempo después él tomaría la difícil
decisión de salirse del negocio familiar
esta etapa de mi vida yo no me la podía
explicar porque les pidió salirse
después de 21 años y de tener la gran
oportunidad de estudiar siempre con este
enfoque en empresas familiares grande
fue mi sorpresa cuando me topo con un
dato impresionante resulta ser que la
mortandad de las empresas familiares es
de más de un 75% única lo que quiere
decir esto que de 10 empresas familiares
únicamente 3 están sobreviviendo
pero por qué fracasan muchas de ellas es
porque carecen de una planeación
estratégica otras por una falta de
formación en el ámbito familiar y
empresarial pero cuál creen que es la
que más está afectando piénsenlo
bueno la que más se está afectando hoy
en día es por una falta de plan de
sucesión y déjeme decirles que es muy
interesante porque cuando he platicado
con los fundadores siempre me dicen
caros que estoy preocupado porque qué
tal si mis miembros familiares no pueden
hacer crecer mi patrimonio o qué tal si
no pueden hacer transmitir me lo
filosofía de generación en generación
pero cuando yo les pregunto ya estás
capacitando a tus es sucesores ya
inicias un plan de sucesión
muchas veces la respuesta es que no
y cuánto tiempo creen que puede tardar
un proceso de sucesión piénselo un año
dos años tres años un proceso de
sucesión señores puede tardar diez años
o más
entonces tendríamos que inculcarles a
nuestros hijos desde muy pequeños que no
solamente hay que amar a la empresa
sino que también se tienen que ganar su
lugar para poder formar parte de ella
yo siempre le digo a los fundadores y de
verdad tengo la fortuna de conocer
fundadores de más de 75 años que hoy se
están replanteando crear una misma
visión compartida y que cree en el
resultado está haciendo una fusión
increíble de experiencia de tradición y
de mucha innovación y creatividad que se
está adaptando a las nuevas tecnologías
a ti fundador lo primero que te puedo
pedir es que visualices como debe de ser
el perfil del siguiente sucesor cuáles
deben de ser sus habilidades sus
actitudes y sus conocimientos si deseas
que sean tus hijos yo te pido que desde
pequeños los invites a ponerlos en
práctica todas sus capacidad
y lo más importante fundadores
dedicarles tiempo a capacitarlos porque
nadie nadie aquí es eterno como diría mi
papá a los posibles aspirantes a
sucesores yo siempre les pido que tenga
la disposición de aprender antes de dar
cualquier tipo de propuesta tienen que
conocer al 100% el negocio que recuerden
que para todo crecimiento van a
necesitar del trabajo en equipo
intergeneracional
una familia que me dio una gran lección
de que podemos llamar a la empresa desde
muy pequeños fue en una ocasión que me
invitaron a darles una plática y cuál
iba a ser mi sorpresa que cuando yo
llegué las primeras personas que me
esperaban eran estas dos pequeñitas una
de cinco y una de diez años cuando yo
llegué ya andaban con pluma con papel
dispuestas a juntar todo conforme fueron
llegando a los demás miembros yo muy
discretamente le pregunté a una de las
guías si en verdad ellas iban a
participar y ella muy segura me contestó
por supuesto caro porque desde pequeñas
tienen que aprender a conocer y a tratar
al negocio
fue una experiencia increíble porque no
solamente daban mejores aportes que los
papás y los tíos
sino porque ellas en verdad querían ser
parte del negocio familiar son muy muy
corta edad
las familias que desean trascender hoy
están cambiando por tratar al negocio y
cómo podemos cambiar esta forma de
tratar al negocio a través de una
transformación de una empresa familiar a
una familia empresaria oye claro que es
una familia empresaria una familia
empresaria es aquella que tiene esta
cualidad poderosa de ser resilientes es
decir de poder adaptarse a las
situaciones de crisis y lo mejor las que
realmente se preocupan por
profesionalizarse en todos los ámbitos
que conlleva desde capacitar capacitarse
anticiparse a los problemas el poderse
escuchar entre los miembros familiares y
los colaboradores los que se preocupan
por la innovación y lo más importante
los son capaces de evaluarse como
familia
para realmente decir si se están
cumpliendo con las metas de la empresa
como familia empresaria yo te pido por
favor que establezca reglas
reglas y desde cosas tan sencillas como
definir las responsabilidades los
horarios los sueldos las vacaciones y
cómo lo podemos hacer lo vas a poder
hacer a través de la creación de un
consejo familiar empezando a dividir los
temas familiares de los temas laborales
cada familia es un universo diferente y
por ello las reglas no pueden ser
iguales para todos una familia que me
impresionó fue la que puso como primera
regla en sus reuniones iniciar siempre
con una oración
esto hacía que si llegaban molestos o
estresados por cualquier cosa el hacer
una oración de verdad cambiaba por
completo la actitud de todos
es válido también establecer reglas que
sepas que vayan a unir a tu familia y
que puedan prevenir cualquier tipo de
conflicto y como qué cosas podemos poner
como reglas hubo una familia que en una
ocasión puso requisitos de quien puede
ingresar al negocio familiar y ponía
requisitos como el haber estudiado fuera
del país tener una licenciatura tener
experiencia en el puesto
pero lo más importante señor es que la
empresa de verdad necesite de ese
talento y créanme he conocido familias
que si no cumplen con estos requisitos
son firmes de no aceptarlos
y creo que a veces como papás cometemos
el error de esta falta de firmeza
todo lo que puedan hacer en vida haganlo
para poder prevenir cualquier problema
familiar que pueda destruir a su propia
familia
mucha gente me pregunta claro por qué
crees tanto en las empresas familiares y
un dato que les quiero dejar en mi
plática porque las empresas familiares
generan más del 78 por ciento de los
puestos de trabajo existentes en el país
y aunque hoy tú seas una micro una
pequeña mediana o gran empresa ustedes
están impulsando el desarrollo de méxico
así que el primer cambio que puedes
iniciar hoy que sea el hogar con tu
familia es saber cómo quieren crecer qué
se requiere para crecer y quiénes
estarán comprometidos para este gran
cambio
mi papá mis tíos y estoy segura que mi
abuelo desde el cielo se arrepiente de
no haber considerado todos estos puntos
ya que de haberlo hecho estarían
viviendo un capítulo muy diferente así
que si decides hacer estos cambios estoy
segura que a la generación que llegues
romperás esquemas y tu familia
empresaria trascenderá y te pregunto a
qué generación deseas llegar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]